good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day it is
Wednesday to all who celebrate and
speaking of a gal who seems to be
celebrating hump day in a rather unique
and special way hey Jax how you doing
I'm doing good yes thank you for
noticing I am celebrating hump day with
a sweatshirt that says happy hump day
but then yeah it's crossed out so it
says dump day it's like very cool and
trendy so kind of disgusting
no like like it's so unlike you like
Duty day no like we're dumping boys
of course your mind like always goes to
duty I'm only human she always has Duty
on the mind and what's a fun place
what's a fun fact about this sweater is
one it's from revolve so it's very cool
so it's definitely not poop because
we're all like the girls who wear
revolved don't poop would never and
second thing is I actually bought it for
you because I saw it when I was placing
our valve order I was like oh my God
hump day that's so cute like that's so
me and Claudia will be like my next gift
to her but then I got it and I was like
why not what if I just kept it what if I
just kept it I always want to wear it
but every time I noticed it it's never
Wednesday and finally everything lined
up today I'm wearing the sweater and the
fact that you noticed it like does make
me feel RDH that I didn't give it to you
let me tell you something don't feel RDH
because I live in Manhattan and I really
only have space for so many crewnecks
and if I'm gonna reserve space for a
crew neck it's gonna be from
shopmorningtoast.com so I wouldn't be
too too upset okay I'm not too upset
that I thank you for you know releasing
my burden but I'm glad that you like it
I'm just celebrating hump day it's so
exciting that it's Wednesday
I love when it's an unexpected hump
obviously this is a short work week
because of Labor Day and we are so
grateful to the laborious nature of the
week so
um I just love when a hump day sticks up
on you it's like I wasn't even ready for
it oh and not only is it hump day but
it's also the day that I see Leah
Michelle and funny girl well that's a
story this morning so hold all your
thoughts in I'm very very excited for
you it sounds like it's gonna be amazing
I'm speechless like I'm I actually have
not been this excited for something in
so long I was telling Ben last night
like I think I'm gonna cry you're a part
of something I'm not only am I part of
something but it's something that has
like such deep meaning for me like I'm
literally I am Rachel Berry like I
identified it with her so much growing
up as like the most annoying human being
on the planet and I I literally cannot
wait your fanny brass and stress
Fanny brass and straws from brass and
strats do you think she's gonna perform
that I heard that they're actually not
performing the hits they're not
performing Bryson Streisand and they're
not performing that other song The Man
my man for whatever my man is I am here
what's the deal forever
what's the deal with that song is it
from the movie and not the show yeah it
was never adapted for the stage and it
is exclusively a movie song but it's so
popular especially related to Lea
Michelle because it's one of the songs
she's saying on Glee and it's like this
iconic moment where like everyone's just
[ __ ] fed up with Rachel like she's
like we've had enough of Rachel she's
trying out for I think it's the play
where her and Mercedes like they cannot
decide who to give the lead to so they
both do a final callback and they give
it their all and of course Rachel sings
My Man from Fanny Wright from funny girl
and it's so spectacular like of course
they have no choice but to give the role
to Rachel even though Mercedes was just
as qualified and was never getting the
lead in anything like justice for
Mercedes
um but the the
the performance was so powerful and
that's where Kurt Hummel says right when
she's done like everyone's literally in
tears and Kurt is like she may be
difficult but boy can she sing yes and
that's really just what people have now
adapted from Rachel Berry on to Leah
Michelle like she may be difficult but
boy can she sing okay hold on your
thoughts it's our first story we have a
lot of great stories today so I'm really
looking forward to that and it's
Wednesday which means it's dear toasters
day and we have an update from somebody
who wrote in last week about her husband
and his yellow teeth we did tell her
like she was being a little bit of like
a Naggy [ __ ] wife and her response is
so funny and she was really receptive so
I cannot I'm I love a deer toasters
update and we have two other submissions
from new girlies who are in need of our
Fox Force 5 help so that'll be at the
end of the show great
I'm excited I'm excited too I love an
update oh my man I love him so he'll
never know like the fact like my
excitement for seeing funny girl was
like
100 out of ten and now that there's no
my man and I knew there wasn't going to
be I thought maybe they were changing a
lot of stuff with Leah adding things
taking things out I thought maybe they
would add my man and now my excitement's
like a 50 out of 10 which is still
really high but like I'm definitely
disappointed maybe they'll hear the
cries of the fans once again they keep
trying to do things their own way and
the fans are like stop it we know what's
best for this program yeah maybe they
won't add it for tonight but maybe down
the line
Margaret said just have to see it again
and again and again even though you
didn't do your researching you didn't
see it with beanie and you haven't
watched the movie and you won't have
anything to compare it to
nothing but that's the thing like for me
and I know this is like a problematic
statement but that's me you're
problematic girly like for me the movie
funny girl is Leah Michelle like I only
know what the movie is because I was
such a Gleek growing up I don't really
and I know this is gonna sound crazy
like I don't identify with Barbra
Streisand like whatsoever to be honest
like I don't even really like her like I
know gays do not come for me like I am
still very much an ally I'm just
personally not a barber Gurley like I
really don't know anything about her
she's not my girl so when I think of
funny girl the film and I know it's like
Barbara's role like I am a younger
person who just thinks of it as Leah
Michelle's role you probably wouldn't
even like the movie if you watched it
for sure that's why I haven't by the way
I don't even know what the movie's about
so like for me the fact that moving
forward like my one and only reference
of funny girl will be the Broadway
version with Leah Michelle like I am
okay with that that's enough for you
dayenu okay you've convinced me
I'm like like so convincing these days
yeah you're constantly convincing me but
also it's like you didn't do your
homework and you're telling the teacher
all the reasons why and there's a
teacher ever like yeah you shouldn't
have done your homework well you know
what that's what teachers get for giving
out homework homework is such [ __ ]
conceptually like I If I ever become a
teacher which honestly
maybe I would I would never give
homework pray for these campers like how
do we expect the kids to uh go into
school every day participate in
activities to have a social life spend
time with their friends and family get
some time to relax and take care of
their mental health and also give them
homework like it's just not it's not
feasible I'm not into homework well in
defense of homework
if I'm you by the way I forgot I thought
of something I know who you are yeah
you're that kid in class who's like wait
where are we supposed to have a pop quiz
today never never yeah no yeah that's
you I'm not I wasn't I was not that kid
in class I would never be that kid in
class but now just like as a parent and
as an adult like there are a few things
about homework that which is why they
exist first of all homework and
activities and keeping the kids busy is
important for the kids otherwise the
kids will get up kids are so busy like
they have a lot going on extracurricular
Sports tutoring also it's important for
like your critical learning skills to
learn something in the classroom and
then go home and apply it by yourself
and see if you're able to take what you
learned and apply it no for sure
conceptually yes but I think like after
years of us all going to school like we
realize like [ __ ] we learned in school
like didn't stick
the the important things to knowing how
to read like what knowing how to read
but that's like a learning to ride a
bicycle like you're doing if you're
telling me you're learning to read in
school and then you're using your learn
your your ability to read every single
day in school but not at home you're
gonna forget how to read no but you get
better at it you search you start with
like picture books letter books then you
go into like the Cat in the Hat type
books then you go into the chapter books
and eventually like you're reading Jane
Eyre it's a stage progression of reading
comprehension no for sure okay so I went
to school and I literally never read
Jane Eyre okay you've read other books
no I really didn't I never read the
required reading Wuthering Heights don't
know her Dorian Gray don't know her
so what's your point
that I am a successful wonderful person
who doesn't believe in homework
I think even knowing how to evade your
homework is a skill
oh my God knowing how you are such a
little [ __ ] brat like no Jackie
homework is not helpful like let's just
leave it at that
you're literally that you're Miranda
Cosgrove in School of Rock with the
demerits and the North Stars now I am
but I wasn't when like I wasn't no I
don't think that's how you were as a
student but now like that's who you are
okay fine she's keeping everyone on
track there's a reason like she's a
manager you went home and like Googled
what a groupie is and you're gonna
report Ned schnee blade to the principal
played by Joan Cusack well it's
inappropriate for the kids to be
groupies for sure literal what is like
the what is the kid version of a Karen
like because you're not a Karen by any
means but like Miranda Cosgrove was like
um
yeah
snitch you're a [ __ ] snitch
[ __ ] like
no because I don't think I would tell
the teacher that you didn't I would
actually never even adult me I would
never tell the teacher that I didn't do
your homework I'd just be the friend
that'd be like Claude this is why we
should do our homework homework is cool
homework is fun and then I wouldn't be
your friend like for real I'd be like
that Jackie but I'm so cool and funny
you can't resist me I would be like guys
isn't that redheaded girl Jackie looks
so [ __ ] annoying oh my God no that's
toxic you're the annoying girl in class
okay I'm the annoying girl you're the
toxic girl
fair fair we all have our strengths
so I'm ready to dive in I don't have
anything else to catch up on you how's
rodini how's Bryce
Etc thank you for asking about Bryce it
was a rough night for Bryce maybe we
should talk about wait why was it a
rough night because he woke up he was
sleeping with Mommy which he does now
which is so gorgeous not every night but
most nights and I woke up to him
throwing up
and it was so it was so sad so I was
like up at midnight cleaning up his
throw up uh
and then I just the whole night I was
just so worried about him of course it
seems to be okay today he's definitely
taking it easy laying on heating pad
letting his stomach settle but the thing
is with our little angel dogs they have
very sensitive stomachs and a lot of
times they just throw up and it's not
like indicative of any sort of illness
they're just like felt like throwing up
you know yeah also he is getting a lot
of extra food recently since we started
solids like he always gets to lick down
the high chair
um Harry's always like dropping things
for him yeah so he is eating more I'm
not going to say like he's been a
perfect angel and I don't know why this
is happening right now you know so I
know I need to definitely keep a tighter
leash on Bryce I thought I was doing
what was best for him by letting him get
in you know a little a little bit here
and there but no he needs
regimen he's a regimented king he is so
and I have that in common that was sad
for last night and tiresome for me but
yeah that's the worst like when you are
sleeping and you hear the oh my God and
their backs are like
yeah it was really really sad oh poor
Bryce well I'm wishing him the I'm
wishing him well please send him my best
thank you that will mean a lot to him I
know it will I [ __ ] love Bryce but
not as much as I love rodini I missed
you sent me a video
it was really tough like you said I get
rotini content on the hour like whenever
it's on demand I'm spoiled at this point
so for something to really take my
breath away in the way not to be
annoying because like nobody who's
listening will ever be able to see this
video and that's what makes me feel
special
um the way that you sent me a video of
Harry riding on a golf cart with the
wind in his hair like I I really like I
was not okay I will not be okay good and
good come visit and the way I am like
minutes away from kidnapping your child
like he's
to put it simply he's mine well why
don't you just come down here like I'm
looking at the flamingos not only is
World missing you Bryce is missing you
the flamingos are missing us we put up
this gorgeous wallpaper for when we're
together and it's been a few weeks and
they're like [ __ ] I've literally spent
three [ __ ] you've been gone for
what like six weeks
okay I've spent 50 of the time at your
[ __ ] house and it's not enough
[ __ ] come here I'm trying but you know
I'm settling my September calendar oh
okay lady Mary
yeah
I have to look at my agenda yeah yeah
you do that you do that and while you're
looking drop roll dini off at my house
for sure but your wenchy energy yes yes
I become wenchy when I have rodini
withdrawal
and I'm withdrawal from rodini right now
and I'm pissed I am and that video
really ignited something in me stop it
seriously this was cute you have a house
come back it's not funny oh wow I didn't
mail it it's not [ __ ] funny I know
you're not happy I know you're putting
on a smile for the podcast with a family
chat but I know you're not happy so stop
it and come back
the thing about Olivia said Olivia is
happy I see it there's this you realize
the sadness behind those eyes do you
really think I'm not happy
no but for the purposes of this sketch
yes oh okay
great no like I know you're happy but
like not as happy as if Royal Genie was
in my arms you know
for that moment yes but overall you have
to look at the big picture because let's
be real like rodini and I think this is
probably with children in general like
you cannot wait to get your hands on
them and then like your arms hurt after
a couple minutes and like he's pulling
your hair and it's like can someone else
take it right so like to for us to move
back so that you could play with him for
30 seconds of pleasure yeah it's not
gonna work I agree look at the big
picture no lies we're told
and I could yield to you seeing that
this is energy that you're putting forth
but I will be standing my contrarian
ground so oh you contrarian
that'll be different let the games begin
baby let the games begin let the games
be in
uh-huh she's also feeling musical well
it's the funny girl in me which is a
great segue into our first story it is
so without further
Where Are You Bruno needs his auntie
where is Brew he's not feeling well
where is Thrice Thrice he needs his mama
where is do he never comes to work
anymore
yeah can I tell you why yeah
um in our new like we have a very new
schedule since going remote obviously
you guys have noticed especially on
YouTube it takes us a little bit longer
to get the episodes out true so I'm
physically in the studio like doing [ __ ]
until past two o'clock and two o'clock
is when Theo's walk is so I don't want
to disturb his walk so like it would it
would ruin his whole day but like it was
so annoying so true my new schedule
doesn't work for Tigs
this is problematic speaking of
problematic great segue into our first
story Lee Michelle without further Ado
here are the first time stories that you
didn't do need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp it can be tough to train your
brain to stay in problem solving mode
when faced for the challenge in life but
when you learn how to find your own
Solutions there's no better feeling and
a therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver making it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it is convenient accessible
affordable and it's done entirely online
you'll get matched with the therapist
after filling out a brief survey survey
and the great part about it is that it's
really easy to switch therapists if
you're not vibing with the first one
it's super common to like shop around
um until you land on someone that you
really like better help is great because
you can chat with your therapist via
video
um phone call messaging anything like
that and better help is just there for
you to give you the tools that you need
to be the best version of yourself when
you want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com toast to get 10 off your
first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash toast today's episode
is also brought to you by legacybox they
make reclaiming Your Glory Days as easy
as one two three
so Legacy box is easily the company that
I get the most messages about be like
what was that company what was the code
so what's great about Legacy box is that
you can use the code today and send it
in when you're ready so make sure to
Just note this down there is limited
supplies available Legacy box is gonna
take your aging VHS tapes camcorder
tapes eight millimeter film physical
photos and professionally digitize
everything by hand they have a hundred
and ten thousand square foot production
campus right here in America where
you'll get everything back on a thumb
drive a DVD or the cloud so they are
taking your old childhood memories you
know we're all aging out a lot of us
were VHS girls we grew up in the VHS age
and all those memories like Precious
family moments loved ones who maybe have
passed are just sitting on VHS tapes and
getting them digitized it sounds like a
big undertaking it's so easy Legacy box
literally sends you everything you need
the label and you just send it in
they'll email you along the way with
updates on what's going on and you can
choose whether to get it back in a thumb
drive
um we chose a thumb drive but you can
also choose a DVD or the cloud so it's
super safe they're gonna Safeguard your
family's Legacy and you can relax
knowing that your Irreplaceable moments
are going to be easily viewed shared and
passed on for future Generations your
memories are meant to be relived not
chewed up by the VCR or worn away with
time convert your tapes to digital so
you can take them anywhere safely for a
limited time you can get started for
just nine dollars a tape at this special
price there's never been a better time
to convert your entire collection visit
legacybox.com toast to shop their nine
dollar tape sale that's legacybox.com
toast to unlock this morning toast first
offer so that's legacybox.com toast
great okay our first story Leah Michelle
receives six standing ovations
at her first performance of funny girl
four before intermission and two in the
second act Leah Michelle received a
standing ovation Tuesday night before
she even said a word at her highly
anticipated first performance in
Broadway's funny girl the actress made
her Triumph and returned to the boards
after a 13-year absent stepping into the
role of Fanny Bryce in the musical
Revival now playing New York City's
August Wilson theater
cheering her on was an electric crowd of
friends and fans alike from her best
friend Jonathan Groff to their fellow
Spring Awakening co-stars John Gallagher
Jr and Gideon Glick actor Zachary Quinto
was also in attendance as was Tony
winner Harvey fire scene New York
Governor Kathy hokel and prolific
producer Ryan Murphy from Glee and
scream Queens where he worked with Leah
Michelle wow it was star-studded I only
saw that Ryan Murphy and Jonathan Groff
were there yeah in fact the crown went
so wild for Leah Michelle she received a
total of four standing ovations before
the end of Act One including one after
the show's signature tune Don't Rain on
My Parade another two followed in the
show's second act at intermission the
aisles were packed with audience members
gushing about Michelle's vocals her
comedic timing and the all-around
excitement in the house Harvey
feierstein said I haven't had a night
like this in the theater in years wow
yeah okay so I have so many thoughts the
first is this is so appropriate because
yesterday we were literally talking
about standing ovations and how like in
certain circles they've become like
[ __ ] meaningless like everyone just
does it um and on Broadway I would say
like 10 out of 10 times at the end of
the show when everyone's bowing like
ever what about the show like you're
getting a standing ovation but to get a
standing ovation multiple times in the
middle of the show it's like kind of
unheard of yeah and it's so spectacular
and I'm so I mean none of this is
surprising to me this was clearly the
role that Leah was born to play we've
all known this for so long people tried
to ignore it but you know the universe
is going to do what the universe is
going to do and it was meant to happen
this way I'm not surprised at all that
the reviews are literally 10 out of 10.
she was incredible a lot of what you
just read from that New York Post
article like it's giving like old
Hollywood like it's like a night at the
theater this is what like New York needs
if Harry Styles was talking about this
show he would said it just feels like a
show at the theater like oh right like a
show where you go to the theater the
theater like a like a show yeah it feels
like a show
it's so exciting as someone obviously
who has tickets and is going tonight and
is so [ __ ] excited
um I'm happy for Leah Michelle I think
she's had you know a rough couple of
years and additionally professionally
yeah personally she's thriving she's
married she had a baby
um obviously we all know about her big
Scandal she took some time off I do
think that's why she wasn't offered the
role at first even though they keep you
know saying that production you know
assumed that she wasn't ready to get
back to work because she had recently
had a baby
um Leah is going along with that too
no when they when they chose beanie okay
Leah's going along with that narrative
as well
um saying like and she did like she had
a really tough pregnancy she was on bed
rest for her first trimester
um so they're all like kind of saying
that as the reason because now that it's
now that it's done and we see Leah like
there's really even more questions as to
why it wasn't her from the beginning
that she didn't get the role at first
because no okay okay I think that though
if if she really turned it down because
she was busy with new mama life like
that's so respectable but of course and
totally understandable but I think
that's a lot for Leah right like for
Leah the opportunity to reprise the role
be eligible for the Tony is something I
think she might have struggled with you
know the decision of whether or not to
do it like
as it pertain to Motherhood but she
would have done it like we know Leah is
extremely ambitious especially as it
relates to this role right okay
she would have done it but I'm glad that
they've come to some sort of you know
light line about
why she didn't get it at first yeah that
they're all working together to pull the
wool over our eyes but it's not working
yeah no I mean it is sad that she won't
be eligible for the Tony but I think
like this critical Acclaim this lit like
everyone fawning like even people who
dislike her admitting that she was
incredible like I think honestly in a
lot of ways that's just as good as a
Tony especially for someone who's like
been canceled and is now coming back but
she'll be eligible for a Tony at some
point now for this no I no I do believe
I do believe you're only eligible when
you reprise the role like when the show
first comes out like The Lion King can't
win a Tony right now really yeah I'm
like almost 100 sure
that's not right no I know which is why
a lot of people like saw it as a slap in
the face Talia
but you know what like everything
happens the way that it's meant to
happen this is definitely her comeback
and she's probably Overjoyed I mean I
saw I tried not to watch like any
footage but obviously somebody leaked
don't write on My Parade I did not watch
it but I did watch her bow at the end
and she was sobbing like this is an
amalgamation of so many things like one
a comeback from a scandal is so hard
um I think it's much harder for a woman
usually so there's that she's a mom now
so everything just like means more this
is the role 20 years in the making like
it's extremely emotional for her yeah
also I didn't realize that the uh the
person who plays Fanny's mom is Tova
felcha she just started the role too she
I love it from um I know we never
watched it crazy ex-girlfriend but
apparently the crowd was going wild for
both Putin and hollering hooting and
hollering so you'll see him tonight
so excited like it's it's and you know
what it's only the second night there is
a matinee today so it will be Leah's
third show
I'm just I don't think like a lot of
celebs are gonna be at the matinee I'm
like we're really curious who's gonna be
at the show tonight yeah Andy Cohen what
are you gonna wear I don't know I didn't
get anything and like I should have I
might go to like Zara today I need like
a cute dress you do you need to wear a
seam lot you need to pay respect to the
theater you can't go there like wearing
toast merch I'm sorry
I mean I could because like it's
literally shot no I know but like that's
I think people especially tonight like I
think everyone I'm gonna look glamorous
yeah I'm gonna wear heels like it is
raining but I am gonna wear like a nice
outfit yeah oh I love that yeah I'm I'm
I really can't say anything other than
the fact that like I'm so excited and
I'm also like happy for Leah Michelle
everyone deserves a second chance no
matter who you are even though I was
refreshing Twitter like during the show
wanting to see what people were saying
and there was like one reporter who was
there it was like third Standing Ovation
fourth sit like he was giving us and the
way people are like so unforgiving of
Leah Michelle or just like people in
general who they deem to have been like
problematic it's so sad like okay she
was a wench she got literally so famous
when she was 16 and decided to make it
everyone else's problem and
I just think we need to have a little
bit more grace honestly 100 no people
are just jealous and wenchy and they
don't end up jealous they're
don't pay them any mind she's no I know
I just was shocked that like that's
still I mean it was Twitter which is
like where miserable people go to exist
so I but I just was shocked at like the
sheer volume of like that that many
tweets with that narrative yeah
yeah like she's been severely humbled
let's give her a chance totally and it's
clear that she's earned it and she's
yeah
she's the right woman for the job so you
know what say what you want but
I don't remember this sort of fanfare
for Beanie no and that's I don't
remember the governor showing up I just
I hope beanie wherever she is today is
doing okay yeah uh Vogue followed uh lee
Michelle around I think yesterday or the
day before and like photographed her and
did like a little interview and they
were obviously like trying to get juicy
and she is not she's not giving people
Lee Michelle she's not giving people
anything as it pertains to Leah as I
mean as a percentage to beanie as it
pertains to not getting the role at
first as it pertained to the reading
literally
I think that the reading okay I think I
don't know why I'm sitting like this but
I'm like getting really impassioned I
think that like this whole thing Liam
Michelle can't read is like the lowest
form of Comedy it's literally not funny
she obviously can read she memorized an
entire script for the show for Glee for
10 years like it's so [ __ ] stupid and
people who keep making the jokes are
genuinely people who are not funny and
like it was funny what sorry like when
we discovered that theory three years
ago like it was kind of funny but we
moved on because we're normal
um and the people who created the theory
those podcasters like they're funny but
now it's like it's not funny anymore and
I I think like it bothers me so much
however I don't think anything has ever
been handled worse than Leah Michelle
has handled this thing because not only
has she been asked about it like very
few times her answers are always
terrible and most recently she said that
she's like people are only saying this
because she's a woman and the way I hate
that [ __ ] answer sometimes it's true
sometimes it's not and people aren't
like making fun of her like because
she's a woman
yeah I just not that she needs to you
know
prove anything to anyone but if this
conspiracy theory really bothers her and
I'm sure it really comes up for her now
anytime there's like Aaliyah press press
conversation it's like why not just read
for us and just
show us you can read what if you just
read
I'm sure that's why Ben loves her though
oh my God that is why Ben is so excited
because she's also a woman who doesn't
promote literacy
uh you know what like it doesn't bother
me
um that people still talk about it I do
still see some funny stuff about it and
I just think she should read for us do a
live reading
because there's also like did you see
that video of her
at an award show where she announced the
winner and she didn't read the card yeah
no and did you also see like the memes
going around you know she released a
book yeah it's like a journal yes it's a
journal where you have to read and write
not her
it's so funny yeah and like I think she
just should do a live reading put it to
bed of course she read scripts for Glee
and for
funny girl but she also could have done
like audio so
yeah for sure but like I've had enough
it's like not funny it's like it's just
she doesn't let it die no she because
she want a dress because she won't read
it for us no I think that she thinks
it's so insulting that like to even
dignify it within response would be
beneath her and I get it but she's
making it worse yes and she's continuing
it yes yes
laughs
but I do think it's really a innocuous
conversation
and I I can sense that it bothers her
but it's very
moronic yeah neutral
yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah there seems to be major trouble in
Paradise between Tom Brady and Gisele
okay and they could be heading for
divorce is what the the papers are
saying the way I'm so shook by this and
I sent you the story last night because
I wanted to talk about it today and the
way I found out about this story is the
most psychotic thing ever do you want to
hear Ben
Zach Shapiro was like I cannot believe
Tom Brady and Gisele and I felt like a
weird like a loser so I went on Twitter
and Googled it and that's when I found
the page six article and I was like not
Zach Shapiro breaking news to me I was
on FaceTime with Olivia last night too
and he started talking about Tom and
Gisele I already knew it but I was like
wow that travel to you really quickly
like because this is fresh shoes and
it's also and he was like how did I not
how did he not know about this I'm like
because it's not confirmed it's his
reports Rumor Mill but they're saying
that there's they could be headed for
divorce because giselle's upset that he
unretired at the time he retired to
focus on family and his personal life
and then you know
backtracked to not focus on family not
focus on his personal life and this is
allegedly not working for Giselle she
went to Costa Rica to take a break from
him oh and now they're saying there's
major marital tensions and they could be
heading for a divorce I I know I'm like
constantly in denial but I don't believe
this yeah I mean this is like and I
think why Zach Shapiro is sofa Clemson
like a lot of people are is because much
like Karen huger's marriage like this
marriage is really an institution it's
like they've been together forever and
obviously in Hollywood anything goes but
when two people have been together for
so long like you just kind of forget
about them like they're set and they're
solid like the possibility of them
getting divorced never even crossed my
mind is something that could happen
because they've just been together
forever yeah also he unretired so many
months ago so wouldn't that have been
the time to take a break go to Costa
Rica like now it's months and months
later they haven't settled this or maybe
it's because football season's about to
start oh Sunday night and it's fresh and
he's like practicing a lot and she's
like stop I don't know if
I believe this but I do kind of see how
like as a wife when your husband retires
again money's No Object your husband
retires to spend time with his family
and then changes his mind six months
later her phone's kind of a hurtful yeah
you're false so
I don't know while it does sound like
unrealistic the core reason for it is
not crazy no not crazy at all I just
given that they're such an institution
they're such a team she's had his back
like she's forever the most ride or die
wife I think yeah in the industry
that there's such a disconnect on this
is very surprising
yeah I mean I like when I saw the
headline I couldn't even read I'm like
these words don't make sense yeah
I don't know if it's true but I hope
it's not I hope it's not a beautiful
family
I just I don't believe it
I guess we'll have to see what happens
on oh
Sunday night we'll have to say
you know what I was thinking is that
song on Spotify
the NBC version I'm gonna guess no it
should be sometimes but those theme
songs are on available to stream but it
is a real Carrie Underwood Miranda
Lambert song oh something bad yeah so
you could get a version of it but
they're not singing about Sunday night
they're singing I don't think so because
they also only have like a 30 second
version of it it's not like a three
minute song no when you watch the whole
thing she's like running from room to
room there's all these like teams she's
talking about like it's a real song but
like the whole it's like a music video
yeah two verses two choruses and a
bridge I don't know about the bridge but
definitely two verses and two choruses
well you could you could do you could be
like really janky rip it from YouTube
put it in your iTunes and listen to it
like back in the day yeah like download
LimeWire yeah no it's like now it's like
YouTube MP3 converter yeah.com
dot com yeah we're pretty big into Tech
what can we say we're AV girlies anyways
moving on from Tom and Gisele I just
hope this this isn't true and even if it
is true that they're able to get past it
right marriages are tough I don't know
if this is worth ending it over so maybe
they're just going through a rough patch
yeah we've all been there we've all been
there are you ready for our next story I
really truly deeply madly am it is a
twofer
are you ready for a twofer subset A and
B we're going to start with Courtney
subset Kourtney Kardashian is launching
a new brand called Lemmy So Courtney
posted on Instagram yesterday some
sickening visuals of a new brand that
she's launching called Lemmy it's her
sitting in a really cute Pliny chair
with a jersey that says Lemmy pink thigh
high boots it was like very Kylie
aesthetic energy and it said like
something's coming you know subscribe
for the notifications a Brand's called
Lemmy and then lmme
which is I think such a cute name I mean
I don't know what the product is so I
don't know if it's gonna be a good name
but I think like it's a it's a good word
it's like very topical I like it and
it's let me live right and I think
that's so her brand like I'm just living
life let me live right right so it's
gonna be like let me live and it's
making me think it's like products in
which to live with yeah so uh they're
they haven't dropped what the actual
company is so a lot of people a lot of
people are making horrible predictions
like she's sitting on a chair it must be
Furniture like no it's literally just
one photo like we don't like there's
probably nothing in the product that
even I'm nothing in the photo that
resembles a product we have to remember
who Courtney is yes we do she is a
wellness girly she has push like
whatever she does has to work with push
and this is giving like Ollie vitamins
like gummies supplements matcha powder
vital protein okay but if she was
launching a line of consumer products in
the wellness space why wouldn't it just
be push branded because that brand is
strong in the wellness space for sure
maybe it's because she
'd prefer to avoid being compared to
goop because goop does goop supplements
like
I don't know I don't know if it's that
my prediction even though I don't think
this is what it is but if I have to
guess I feel like it could be a line of
like organic foods
like I can see her doing that but from a
business perspective like I don't know
how that's
gonna make her a billionaire you know
yeah
Lemmy
let me let me get some let me let like
it's like let me live then it's like
live products for Living products in
which to live but then you also need to
think about all the other Kardashian
Associated Brands like let me live I was
thinking like maybe it could be like a
home but then there's like safely you
know maybe she would do like but that
doesn't stop them from crossing over we
had Kylie cosmetics and kkw beauty
like yes but that's because the girls
are makeup icons like they're not
cleanliness icons like if they both came
out with a Surface Cleaner it would be
[ __ ] weird is kkwbd ever coming back
like what about the body foundations
what are we supposed to do without them
I don't I'm running low I don't know and
that's not right to get us hooked on a
product and then I agree Hooked on
Phonics and then phonics goes away no
no information no goodbyes no telling us
like where it was manufactured so I
could buy you know the the generic brand
that was the same as Kylie same color
pop color pop
the interesting thing about this is that
and I'm sure this was intentional the
way that they're like dropping hints and
people are just like genuinely curious
like it's such good marketing for the
brand and it's driving me nuts I also
thought maybe it would be like sex
positive like plastic free like
vibrators
because the logo on the Instagram is
like this like rubber like yeah material
looks like silicone it's giving vibrator
unless it's like silicone dishes and
plates that are like non-toxic baking
you know like Caraway home Vibes and I
love my Caraway I really don't know I
feel like that could be it non-toxic
cookware and things in which to live and
eat plates like how you know what babies
have like the silicone no I get it yeah
I I'm gonna stick with like collagen
powders supplements gummies
she's like you know
herbal Queen okay I'm sticking with my
guest which is
um not necessarily food but things to
eat your food with that are non-toxic
no that's a good idea but I think mine's
better so far away
far away no it would be Caraway with a k
also she's doing a collaboration with
boohoo which was also announced
yesterday to much less Fanfare okay the
sustainability ambassador
is Kourtney Kardashian she's coming I
have a thought sustainable lineup boohoo
while I commend boohoo's efforts to be
sustainable because like they're one of
those like top five fast fashion
companies that are literally destroying
the planet this feels so off brand for
Courtney I was like so shook one because
she's like so you know clean cons like
conservation environmental girly and
boohoo is like the worst of the worst
yeah
and like it just felt random yeah well I
mean unless she's gonna clean up their
whole act in which case that right but
that she just seems like a really big
Endeavor she's not it's just like her
line is gonna be like a little less bad
for the planet
it's it was kind of like giving
fraudulent energy
yeah especially when she has this big
thing kicked off also I want to mention
that she has filed a trademark for the
brand
um with the production of quote bags
purses totes wallets clutches and
clothing with additional categories
including games toys and Sporting Goods
wait what so that doesn't necessarily
tell us anything maybe she wants to like
cover every category and it could be
like you know a subset of
clothing mm-hmm like what if it's like
merch could be like lingerie or it's
like a cool brand that she makes up of
like whatever vitamins and then they
make merch yeah yeah yeah totally
that is unique I hope we get answers
soon I know I feel like it's going to be
a while well you if you want to get your
notifications on let me live.com let me
live.com
okay I'm really I like my guess I feel
good I like mine okay good
good because it's the one you got and
then subset B of Kardashians launching
new brands Kim is launching a private
Equity Firm kakai Partners to help
budding entrepreneurs so Kim is
expanding her ever-growing resume once
more the skims founder is launching a
new private Equity Firm alongside a
former partner at Carlisle Group Inc J
Salmons The Wall Street Journal reported
on Wednesday now Carlisle Group sounds
familiar because they're the group that
helps Scooter Braun buy Taylor's master
so that's just an interesting fact Twain
the firm is called Sky partners s-k-k-y
KK for Kim Kardashian not sure if you
guys knew that the firm pill The Firm
will make investments in areas like
consumer media and entertainment
businesses consumer products luxury
hospitality and digital Commerce and
media the outlet explained according to
a post from an Instagram account for the
company The Firm will focus on both
control and minority investments in high
growth market-leading consumer and media
companies okay like not to make this the
toast about us I thought the same thing
instantly we are ready to be invested
into spread my legs I'm ready we're
literally consumer Media Company we're
high growth and I don't know what other
consumer media companies that are big
enough out there that aren't already
purchased that aren't taking Investments
right like Barstool is got their
investment yes yeah I feel like we're
you know the only free agent
we can be bought Kim we can be bought we
can just wanna you know like this kakai
hasn't reached out to us no but but I
have a feeling they're gonna me too I do
feel as though with this business
venture is like a great idea I figured
it was probably something Kim already
did like she's always investing in stuff
remember when she she was like a
co-owner of Lumi the phone cases that
she helped make famous like she's been
doing this on a small scale for so long
I just figured she definitely had her
own Fund in some way but now that she's
doing it as like a public-facing thing
which obviously makes sense because
that's her superpower it's smart like
genius yeah and she'll invest in brands
that she promotes ensuring their success
very very cool yeah I look forward to
seeing what she missing honestly they
said they were gonna like make an
investment Announcement by the end of
the year
oh yeah I mean that it's really like a
win-win because not only are you getting
an investment for your company which is
great but you're also now on this like
global scale uh being one of Kim
Kardashian's brands that she believes in
and it's just gonna even that it's like
going on Shark Tank but it's honestly
bigger no it reminds me of like Ashton
Kutcher because now yeah we mostly know
him a lot as an investor for investing
and everything but at the time it's like
he'll invest in your brand he'll give it
the money that it needs he'll gives it
the legs and it's a whole machine so I
actually think that this is
though surprising
genius not yeah I'm ready for Kim on
Shark Tank it's like enough already no
that's where we're headed with this I
know Kim Kardashian of skakai Ventures
joins the tank right first pitch TNN
good morning sharks we are looking for
601 charquette
we aren't no well there's other
shortcuts too Jackie well not on every
episode of course because the men's day
but they rotate out the window but but
there's usually at least one there has
to be one woman so there's never not
Lori or Barbara so it's two shortcuts
minimum maybe three sharks and shark
pets good morning sharks we are seeking
we are seeking a 600 million dollar
investment for a one percent stake in
our company the morning toast where
we're literally Geniuses and everything
we do is perfection and we don't really
need to explain ourselves further
because if you don't know the toast
you're an irrelevant ugly and
um a big faced wench
yeah what'd she say thank you
um just watch an episode give us a call
have a spritz a little talk yeah we have
many revenue streams we are extremely
business savvy as Lori would say we're
heroes not zeros and we're just gonna
make you money and US money and that's
the dream the American dream
and we are available for beyond the tank
segments I love the beyond the tank
segments I know we will participate
eagerly
so this is cool I'm very curious what do
you think about the Carlisle group is it
just a clinky dink I think it's a
coincidence like people are like the
Carla group it's literally one of the
biggest
like uh what are they even like private
wealth management like private Equity
Firm yeah like it's what it's like a
black stone it's Taylor Swift and Kim
like they don't own it it's like one of
the world's biggest funds of money so
like if Kim is gonna do something top
tier she's gonna go to Carlisle Group
same way scooter Brawn needed money he
was top tier went to I don't think it
has anything to do with each other
everyone just keeps trying to make these
moments happen between the two and like
they're not going to happen no they're
not going to happen but it's possible
that Kim and scooter are both like
they're in the same circles Kanye used
to work with scooter they're good
friends so maybe like she even knows
about it just from her time with him or
like they're both just like really rich
and really rich people go to the best
place and the best place is Carlisle
perhaps
that's like two celebrities that's like
two celebrities eating at Craig's not
because they both went but because
that's where the good people eat do you
think that this is the private Equity
man who Chloe was seeing
oh
the thought literally never occurred to
me but the answer is a hundred percent
yes but now we need to take a better
look at him hold on he's handsome
now Kim is going into business with
Chloe's ex then
maybe it was amicable
like if Kim was working with him and
they started dating Kim this project has
obviously been in the works for a while
like you don't just start a VC so
he was Kim's business partner first and
then Chloe's man so Chloe can't ask her
to not work with him okay
oh my God he's so cute by the way like
obsessed he kind of looks like Shango
he does kind of he looks like
businessman chango
I'm obsessed should we follow should
Tien and follow Sky Partners so we're on
their radar oh done and also so I
thought you're gonna say so we can get
updates
no so that like they're like looking for
perspective how many followers does Sky
have 23
000 and let's see how many Lemmy has
let me well Skye has barely been
launched
same with Lemmy no but Courtney posted
about Lemmy I think I saw in Liz
Height's Instagram that Kim posted about
Skype and then deleted it
Lemmy has 55. because that's 24 hours of
promotion whereas this I don't know what
happened with the launch but Kim deleted
her promotion of it
I don't think she was ready
yeah she ready
okay ready for our next story while
we're only on story four with all these
steps
um but it's some gorgeous news because
Guy Fieri's on the cover of People
magazine talking about making family his
first priority and his calling to give
back the way I know nothing about Guy
Fieri's personal life he's a wife kids
which is why we need him on the toast
and which is why he's a dream guest so I
was like nobody knows the real guy we
would get down to the nitty-gritty guy
like you've never seen him before
hashtag who's the real Guy Fieri
let's get him on 100
um so anyways on the cover of this
week's people Guy Fieri's opening up
about raising his sons to be
self-sufficient philanthropy and his new
Food Network show guy's ultimate game
night he says quote I think that I've
definitely mellowed he swathed head to
toe black wearing his favorite chain
necklace embossed with a skull and the
chef's hat chunky silver rings his
trademark OT and a thick thistle of
split spiky bleach blonde hair along
with a mischievous smile that's daring
someone to contradict him he's so
Miserables he's mischievous oh really I
needed a nap after having breakfast this
video says his publicist taking the bait
anyways the mayor of flavor town is
opening up saying I still like to have
fun still stay busy there are so many
experiences to be had so why not take
advantage of it today Fieri is one of
the most powerful food celebrities in
the world anchoring six shows including
his newest guy's ultimate game night
while running 85 restaurants a
production company his Santo tequila
business with his pal Sammy Hagar and
his new knuckle sandwich by Espinoza
cigar lime what in the knuckles sandwich
I have to say I literally would take
several bullets for Guy Fieri however
one of the worst meals I ever had was at
one of his restaurants
he doesn't have good quality control I
mean with 85 restaurants it can be hard
no I know I know not every all of them
can have a guy's stamp of approval but
at least I didn't have to pay a lot it
was reasonably priced now Bobby Flay on
the other hand robbing people blind
while also poisoning them and selling
their recipe he said knowing what's in
them and then just adding the
ingredients and ambushing ambushing
people in their towns like off to a
cook-off
so wrong
so wrong in May 2021 guy signed a
three-year contract with food network
worth an estimated 80 million dollars
making him the highest Chef in uh
paycheck in network history he says my
friends most of my friends will say I
haven't changed I think it's because
when I got into television I'd already
done what I wanted to do I wanted to be
a great dad oh
wait the way that he's the highest paid
Chef on television and literally I've
never once seen him cook anything he's
like more of a personality he goes to
other people's diners he hosts Guys
Grocery Games I know he's a professional
eater yeah he's not really does he know
how to cook
that's a really great question it's a
great question for sure
I just won't talk anymore
I just won't
I'm sorry I won't ask great questions
anymore I'm so sorry
um anyways if you want to know more
about guy pick up this month's week
sorry it's weekly People magazine and oh
I will hope that one day he comes on the
toast for a sit-down interview guy like
you've never seen him before you know
yesterday we started a list of the
people who can save Hollywood and I've
wanted to add two more people can you
write this down because I think this is
a list we should actually have written
down we had Kiki Palmer Kelly Clarkson
and Brendan Fraser
who can save
Palmer
Kelly
Brendan Fraser and Sadie Singh oh yeah
Guy Fieri obviously
so not Hollywood though but I know and
that's like why he could save it you
know yeah
and I had a final candidate I'd like to
put forth um I just need your approval
Keith Urban
sure because like he's so normal but
he's also in Hollywood because of Nicole
Kidman
but he actually could save it
okay I like that thanks we'll continue
to add to the list
let me know if you have any suggestions
sound off in the comments
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is the final story
Guy Fieri I take a bullet for you oh and
by the way that list of people who can
save Hollywood is also happens to be the
list of the people I would take several
bullets for
great love little list crossover you do
love to see it okay our next story is
some Biz news from the influencers
forest has released their top creators
of 2022 based on earnings there's top 50
creators it's not really in order of how
much people are oh my God what a mess
the website was I was literally just
trying to read this dumbass article and
first of all it made no [ __ ]
sense people kept showing up multiple
times like I just was being nosy I don't
want to see how much money people were
making like let me live no totally the
article is a mess the interface is a
mess the only thing we're interested in
is how much everyone's making we don't
care what you think they're
entrepreneurs ships for You Know Nothing
Jon Snow and this editorialized version
of the top creators it's not what I'm
here for but we can glean from this data
who are the highest money earning
creators but see I like so in order to
have made the list and for them to have
put your numbers on line you had to
submit uh paperwork like tax paperwork
yes and I also know that they did not
tell the creators that the amount of
money they make would be public
information
um so that seems kind of [ __ ] up
because I'm sure a lot of people would
not have wanted to participate if they
knew that their you know salaries were
going to be put online because first of
all puts Target on your back house is
going to get robbed like I don't think
many people would want other people
knowing how much money they make
um having said that I did find a lot of
inconsistencies
with the numbers like I'm so [ __ ] I
had a hard time believing
let's go through it yeah I don't know if
we'll make it through all 50 but here's
at least the top ten I can't believe
what you're just telling me
wow
number one is Mr Beast earning 54
million dollars
um they also have the total followers
which for him is 162 million average
engagement six percent and entrepreneur
score entrepreneurship score three so
it's between one and three based on like
do all of your money come from Brand
deals really like an entrepreneur or do
you have multiple revenue streams
businesses that you started do you have
that entrepreneurial Spirit no Mr Beast
um is not only extremely entrepreneurial
and philanthropic I actually recently
was just watching a video about his um
ghost kitchens do you know about it no I
don't really know about a lot about him
me neither but I was like I was so moved
by this like thing so you know and I I
don't think they have it in New York but
when I'm on tour and I'm like in my
hotel room like being fat I'll always
like order like some chicken tenders and
everywhere I go it says Mr Beast ghost
kitchen and so basically what during the
pandemic what he did was like start
ghost kitchens where he had a menu of
like really delicious like burgers
chicken like bar food
um but they didn't have any physical
restaurants so they would go into like
Mom and Pop restaurants train the
employees and make them official ghost
kitchens for Mr Beast and then Mr Beast
would promote his Mr Beast Kitchen in
Minneapolis and give this Mom and Pop
Shop like tons of Revenue and help them
not lay off Cuts lay off employees
during the pandemic and it became huge I
think there's like hundreds of locations
now it was actually like like he didn't
do it to make money he has more money
than God like he was really doing it to
help people it was really cool that's
really cool yeah I think he maybe I
think maybe the clip I watched was on
Joe Rogan talking about it I think it
was a podcast I can't remember which one
though yeah they mentioned in the Forbes
article they also like sat down with
everyone that all 50 creators I think
there was a photo shoot and a video
interview
um so very involved and to not tell them
they were going to publish their
salaries again is extremely [ __ ] so I
just heard that from a few people who
were on the list so I don't want to like
be slanderous I feel like that's a good
source number two and he's number one by
a mile he was 54 million dollars in
earnings number two is Charlie demilio
at 17.5 million dollars also earning an
entrepreneurship score of three
yeah she has a lot of businesses she
makes the ring lights she obviously does
social media she does brand deals she
has the reality show she's going on
Dancing With the Stars I believe
entrepreneurial three yes for sure she
has her clothing brand brand social
tourist Hulu show Snapchat and then also
brand deals Invisalign morphe Duncan
she's still posting her dances yeah
she's a little entrepreneur
number three Alex Cooper 20 million
dollars
also entrepreneurship score of three
cool yeah but obviously we all know 60
million dollar deal with Spotify 20
million dollars a year where's that
right uh number four [ __ ] Jerry 30
million dollars see again it's not in
monetary order no it makes no
[ __ ] sense because Jerry number
two
Wild
yes this is a mess
loathe that person whose name you just
mentioned however great business between
the board games you gotta respect the
hustle
um even if you don't respect the person
entrepreneurship score of three three
well-deserved happy for him rolling in
the dough number five Emma Chamberlain
12 million dollars entrepreneurship
score of three for sure she has multiple
Brands podcast she does the Vogue
interviews she's an influencer for
different fashion brands she's she's
three number six Huda Katan 13 million
dollars entrepreneurship score of three
so this is where I feel like the numbers
in this
thing make no sense
um Huda Katan is literally the Charlotte
Tilbury of the Middle East like her
brand and it's huge in America too but
like in because she lives in Dubai in
the Middle East it's enormous so I don't
know it just sounds like too little
yeah the brand has expanded into
skincare and all sorts of cosmetic
goodies retailing direct to Consumer and
in stores like Sephora around the world
helping her reach a net worth of 400
million dollars making her one of the
richest self-made women in the world
so how was her earnings 13 million
dollars like it just doesn't make any
sense great question that's a great
question I felt like the numbers on this
were either so high for some people and
so low for other people yeah number
seven Rhett and Link at 30 million
dollars I I don't know them know them uh
they have a YouTube
Comedy Channel cool number eight cobby
lame 10 million dollars Tick Tock of
course new face of Hugo Boss I just saw
him in Bloomingdale's when me and Ben
were shopping it was so crazy
um what's his entrepreneurial score
three I think to be in the top ten you
have to have a score of three well it's
hard to make that much money just on
like one Revenue stream alone and two
maybe you make a lot of money on brand
deals or whatever but they wouldn't put
you in the top ten if you're not an
entrepreneurial Spirit girly yeah number
nine Addison Ray 8.5 million dollars her
number felt low I feel like between and
what's her entrepreneurial score three
she has a lot of businesses of course
she acts she does social media she does
brandial she started item Beauty she
does like different capsule collections
she's definitely an entrepreneur I just
felt like 8.5 and by the way it's
important to note that these figures are
for 2021. so for what they made in the
calendar year last year and I just felt
like last year was her biggest year yet
and I don't know especially when you now
compare to other now we're getting to
into numbers
um from other people who are similar to
Addison and it's like she definitely
made more than them you know yeah
totally and number 10 which is why this
list is such a crock of [ __ ] is Jake
Paul earning 45 million dollars with an
entrepreneurship score of two now that's
offensive no it's just like P it's it's
a bias because Jake Paul whether you
like it or not is literally Beyond
entrepreneur I was just watching this
video I don't know he was came out with
his tech company he obviously does the
boxing you don't get to make 45 million
dollars every year from a YouTube
channel if you're not extremely
entrepreneurial so and he should with
this number he should be at number two
and his entrepreneurship scores number
three what doesn't Jake Paul do he's
also like there's the stuff that we see
that he does and then I think he also
does a ton of other stuff in Bitcoin
like yeah no that just seems like an
intentional slight against Jake Paul for
sure yeah shall we keep going yeah next
is Mark Edward Fishback Marky plier no
clue no clue uh he you could skip the
people we don't know for the second time
okay great okay number 12 we don't know
number 13 no no number 14 Patrick Star
oh 50 million dollars that sounds right
his beauty company one size is so
popular actually I use their settings
for this morning number 16 the bias
strikes again Danielle bregoli at 51
million dollars she should be number say
what you want she should be number two
entrepreneurship score is a one even
though she owns and operates her only
fans channel right and she does uh also
She's a beauty company to go from being
like the cash me outside girl on Dr Phil
to 51 million dollars in one year you
need a ton of [ __ ] entrepreneurial
hundred percent a lot this is really
frustrating I didn't even realize some
of this stuff this is really such lies
well because she's not Forbes approved
right no totally because she's
considered low brow I think the same
could be said for Jake Paul
yeah of course yeah but like we didn't
ask you no we just want the figures we
want the facts and we want the figures
number 17 then is Josh Richards at five
million dollars I feel like he would
make more but okay yeah number 18 Marcus
Brownlee from YouTube no clue 1920 21
Dixie dimilio 10 million dollars that
sounds accurate 22 new toaster Danny
Austin Ramirez oh my God okay I saw this
8.2 I need to talk to Danny Austin
um question mark yeah well I think a big
stream for her is Divi which is the uh
like her hair care I've used it for a
postpartum hair loss it's a scalp serum
and what's crazy is like it's a brand
it's a whole line but it's really just
that one serum right that like launched
it yeah Forbes reported that she had 23
million dollars in sales to date well
also and I know this is only considering
money from 2021 but I saw a lot about
Danny Austin obviously I became familiar
with her a few weeks ago when she became
a Toyota her and I just like love to see
it then you know the um like the water
bottles that everyone's obsessed with
Stanley yeah so they released like their
new generation and they like did the
collab with Danny Austin exclusively
like on commission and like they
literally I'm sure in one day she made a
million dollars it was so crazy that's
cool yeah uh number 25 our first fashion
girly here Ami song at 2.8 million
dollars I'm sorry to still be on that
list when you have been like at the top
of the blocker game for 10 years is so
impressive yeah
like she stays relevant good for her
there are a couple fashion people on the
list this would make her the number one
she has an entrepreneurship score of
three but like where's Kiara Kiara
Jinx where's Kiara then Desi Perkins is
number 26 at 12 million dollars tracks
Brett man rock is number 27 at six
million dollars
Brett man rock is the best influencer of
all time period like I don't know anyone
funnier or makes better content or
literally like I don't even know I would
say he started as a beauty influencer
now he just does whatever the [ __ ] he
wants and like it's so funny I love
Brett man he's a personality then he
makes more than six million dollars like
he's literally ever he's he comes up on
my Tick Tock every single day Google
partnership like more Noah back number
28 4.5 million dollars
uh Camila Coelho 2.5 million dollars
number 30 another fashion girl both her
and Mommy have lines with revolve yeah
number 32 tanks 11 million dollars with
an entrepreneurship score of one but
sure how how would Brett man Rock make
six million dollars in tinks made 11
million dollars unless she had other
businesses which would make her
entrepreneurship score higher so that's
what's her entrepreneurship so what
they're saying she's met I don't think
she's eight dollars in brand deals right
she doesn't have any businesses of her
own like it's just brand deals and well
I guess it's from 2021 she went through
like a major Scandal and I don't think
she gets brand deals anymore
um but in 2021 she did but I don't see
this is where I felt like the the list
really started to make no sense like
Brett man Rock making 6 million number
33 Ricky Thompson 2.5 million same thing
like Ricky Thompson is like brands are
obsessed with him
he is has so many followers but he has
an entrepreneurship score of three
oh but from what what does it say in the
description I feel like he just does
brand deals he's three million followers
on Tick Tock has done sponsored content
for Brands like YSL Beauty Montclair and
Marc Jacobs he also is a regular face of
Coach campaigns he also has a Spotify a
Spotify podcast we said what we said and
is starting in his first feature film
good morning with Machine Gun Kelly
Megan Fox and Dove Cameron oh sounds I
feel like that would be a level two
entrepreneurial yeah when that just
doesn't make sense if Ting says 11
million dollars and an entrepreneurship
score of one
that's just very congruous right no like
I felt like this whole chart was
confusing to me then number 36 your girl
Michaela 2.4 million dollars right okay
so this is where the list officially
became nonsense to me because I heard
Michaela neguero if you want to work
with her she's booked two years out in
advance she's 13 million followers on
Tick Tock she is easily the most
influential person on the platform she's
certainly the most influential person in
the beauty space she does Partnerships
she is so [ __ ] Rich it's like
multiple ads a day from premium ass
companies you're telling me she made
what 2.4 million dollars
but and I don't know why I'm like
focused on tanks but like tink's making
11 million dollars like
which is not true score of one I just
want to say and they didn't write if she
does have other businesses they didn't
reference and they talked about her
brand deals her podcast and her Chipotle
Bowl that's named after her so that was
an entrepreneurial score of three you're
saying yes maybe it was more like they
sat down but the person like got a Vibe
of like their entrepreneurial levels
because this article makes no sense no
no it makes no sense but still we
appreciate that like I'm just glad that
I appreciate like knowing what
everyone's up to because I'm nosy and
annoying knowing what everyone's up to
and that like creators are getting
respect like they should be yeah Forbes
world and I think a lot of people have
found this so [ __ ] interesting yeah
no and I'm curious how the creators feel
about like their personal finances being
on blast because I do think it would
make a lot of them probably feel
uncomfortable yes agreed shall I
continue or no you're good Okay cool so
those are the top creators asterisk
right 2021 and I feel as though you
needed to know that I definitely think
you needed to know that and what you
also needed to know is today's deer
toasters our Wednesday advice segment
you write into deertoesters gmail.com
and we'll
show you the world I don't know how to
finish that sentence
um and it's brought to you by studs
sure I'm not talking to you anymore
today's episode is brought to you by
just both talk at the audience like not
to each other
today's episode is brought to you by
studs you've probably noticed the
ultimate cool girl look is in and a
fully loaded stacked earscape is in if
that feels a little intimidating then
you got to check out studs they coin the
term earscape and they are the go-to
Authority for piercings and earrings and
can help you create curate and ear
Escape based on your own anatomy and
style studs is reimagining the piercing
experience for each and every ear if you
want to refresh your look with new
piercings or you need Pro styling advice
you can shop online or in their stud
stores in La New York City Austin
Nashville Miami Boston or Seattle and
they have more coming soon
so there's something like a parsing
party if you want to get your ears
parsed for the first time studs does it
super well their brand you can trust
they're clean they have Stylus they know
exactly where to put it you're not going
to get some wonky hole
um and they make such cute jewelry if
you're wanting to get into like the
stacking game or if you just want
something simple head to the store or
head to the website to find everything
that you need I have a ton of earrings
from studs I have two holes in one ear
and then one in the other so I'm not
like crazy but I'm kind of edgy with my
second hole you know edgy
um they're made from high quality
materials which won't turn your skin
green they're lightweight and durable
enough to wear all the time you can even
sleep and work out in them they have
over 250 styles of Hoops Huggies studs
cuffs and dangles and they pierce way
more than just earlobes so you can
create a statement look or keep
something keep you something you keep in
every day so the earrings start at just
ten dollars per earring and they're
offering our listeners 20 off your first
purchase when you go to studs.com toast
go to studs.com toast for 20 off your
first purchase that's
s-t-u-d-s.com slash toast all right so
we have two submissions and one update
the first Jackson Claude how you doing
learning good I have a dilemma that I
need to talk to you about I need my best
gals I'm ready to hear whatever harsh
but necessary advice is warranted okay
right my boyfriend is of eight years and
I moved in together about a year ago and
since moving in our sex life has been
slim to none we talk about it often
because our work schedules just don't
allow us to see each other at the
sexiest times so I felt that we were on
the same page about it I went to set an
alarm on his phone for work yesterday
and I found him messaging several only
fans girls specifically asking if any of
them would be interested in [ __ ] a
fan quote
also I found different Snapchat accounts
than what I know him as again messaging
girls sending dick pics the whole nine
yards he knows I caught him he was
embarrassed apologetic and said all the
things that I needed to hear I do
believe
him that it wasn't anything more than a
jerk off and he offered to move out or
whatever I wanted him to do I love him
and I'm comfortable and I've worked so
hard on a relationship over the last
eight years that I don't know what to do
he didn't actually cheat from what he
told me help what would the morning
toast do do I break up with this man and
start scratch start from scratch at 28
years old okay 28 is not that old first
of all and obviously like I know
the fact that you've been together for
so long is like making this challenging
when at the end of the day this is like
the least challenging prompt we've ever
had Not only was he keeping all this
from you and lying which is so deceptive
and and is so indicative of like a
[ __ ] up personality trait but he was
doing it with the intent to cheat on you
and the fact that none of these models
want to [ __ ] him like it's just sheer
coincidence like he would have [ __ ]
someone if somebody would have [ __ ]
him if they would quote [ __ ] a fan he's
got to go first of all he doesn't have
time to have sex with you but he has
time to have multiple Snapchat accounts
only fans accounts to be spend any of
that amount of time I'm trying to woo
you even if it's an unsexy time of the
day
this is really bad I mean yeah you had
said like we don't have a lot of time to
have sex but I I see him like he has
only fans he looks at other girls and
like me like watches porn or whatever
that would be a different conversation
but like actively he was looking to
cheat on you he just couldn't get
arrested right which is sad for him and
like you could do better than that as
someone who can't even get arrested
gotta go 28 you're so fine so young and
you didn't even say like this man is
love with my life like he's an angel you
said you said uncomfortable Jackie I
thought the same thing this is your sign
he has absolutely got to go he sounds
like a piece of work and you're will be
so much better off without him also like
the fact that you caught him and his
response was like it wasn't it you
caught him cheating you did and he's
like no I'll be better like I'll move
out like he's giving martyr energy you
have to let this man go he sounds so
[ __ ] toxic and this isn't even a red
flag it's literally like a red blanket
it's huge
goodbye yeah goodbye sorry I'm so sorry
like but no keep us posted on your
single Endeavors yeah like move on I
know it feels like a long time because
you were together for eight years but
it's not like you're 40. you're 28
you're still young you date someone for
one two years get married at 30. that's
normal yeah I was reading that book for
the redhead stali alderton and she had
started it yesterday she said something
pretty good in it she said about
breaking up with someone like if you
could go into a room and push a button
and the breaking up would be done
there's no like Logistics him moving out
this or that you would have him out of
your life and like you would everything
else is taken care of would you do it
wow and that's your answer now I'm kind
of feeling like if that was an option
like I totally do it to Ben it just
sounds so easy like honestly like it's a
little too enticing you know yeah but
I'm totally kidding all the external
factors out of the equation if you could
be rid of this person would you do it I
just want to say I'm totally kidding
like it's a joke and it was funny okay
yeah like should I cut that out like Ben
is going to be mad no no he won't hear
it next up right that's so true hey
Jackson Claude I'm gonna toaster
breather for years and I have this
neighbor who lives across the street
he's like an old man who lives by
himself he looks like Santa Claus but he
wears wife beaters I don't know if we're
still saying wife beaters but whatever I
haven't heard of a better term like a
replacement no but a tank top is like
spaghetti if he's wearing a tank top I'd
be like what the sexy I can't visualize
there's too many too big it's an
umbrella term
so I tried to wave at him or smile at
him over the years but he's never
acknowledged me or my husband anyway I
know being neighborly isn't for everyone
but I've noticed over the past month or
so every night when I'm in my bathroom
getting ready for bed I happen to look
out the window I couldn't see him in his
family room he's literally watching porn
I see him I can't see him but can I
can't see what he's doing but I can only
imagine what he's doing and it's like
close your blinds your laptop slash TV
is facing the window keep in mind I've
never met or spoken to this man so do I
leave an anonymous note letting him know
that people can see or do I just buy my
own business that's so weird it's every
night
yeah and it like looks directly into her
bathroom
get it get a window treatment no that's
like psychotic behavior yeah I know but
what is she gonna do like he's in his
own house minding his own [ __ ]
business I don't she's the one not
minding her own no no but like
that's right no don't do anything don't
get anything to him
it's just put up some plants outside
your window to make plants a shrub MC
plans yeah what is our uh sponsor
fastgrowingtrees.com like look at a tree
yeah
like you can't say anything because one
it's like creepy technically you're the
one like peeping Tom on him and he's not
breaking any laws he's literally just
watching porn so no and it's like you
said it's like a laptop or an iPad so
it's a smaller device it's not like his
television his 80 foot set that he knows
you can see from the street like I'm
sure he would be embarrassed
I would hope that he's being married he
obviously lives alone he's looking for
like some female companionship I just
feel like
he has to know that you can see it and
but people can see it from the street
and like he keeps doing it no you know
what like he's older like older people
don't think of that like we are like
we're born with cell phones in our hands
like we're so conscious of our like of
our phones and like older people like
they don't think everyone's looking
because they didn't grow up looking at
other people's phones you know okay okay
you're convincing me
the convincer the convincer
um I say leave it alone for real like of
course regardless leave it alone put up
a shrub our third and final I've been
just literally waiting we're going on an
hour and a half episode like I've just
been waiting to get to this ready so
last week we had a girl write in about
the fact that her husband
um
was switching to coffee from energy
drinks and was getting like yellow
stains and just his teeth were getting
gross and he says he'll whiten his teeth
but he never makes the appointment and
she was getting really fed up and
basically we told her like yeah no
yellow teeth aren't great but you kind
of sound like a Naggy [ __ ] and like
he's working hard like leave him alone
he made the switch like now it's
something else yeah you were the one who
convinced him to switch to coffee from
Energy Drinks like he's doing his best
now she writes in and I just want to say
I really appreciate her writing in so
quickly because this one was fresh in my
mind
excellent Claude following up on the
husband with yellow teeth first off
thank you for the slap in the face that
I needed I was being so Naggy and
getting an outside perspective really
helped me realize that I definitely need
to pick my battles and I should probably
stop being a petty wench
I was all for never bringing it up again
but guess what happened
we went out to lunch with his friends
and our new baby and my girlfriend
snapped a few pictures when my husband
asked me to show him them later in he
zoomed on he zoomed in on his teeth I
didn't say a word I just said Ah that's
a great picture of you the next morning
I saw whitening strips in the bathroom
thank you again girls see some things
just take care of themselves the
universe works itself out I'm so happy
for you because you win now your
husband's taking care of it and you look
like the cool chill wife who just made a
suggestion no matter what his teeth look
like oh my God and see that's what
happens when you write into the morning
shows like we literally solve every
single one of your problems literally
I'm so happy for you thank you for
trusting us with your problem thank you
for writing in your update right one
week later and I'm so happy that it
worked out for you and I love you and if
you guys want to write in to get advice
from clearly chew like Carmen San Diego
problem solving Queens deertoesters
gmail.com we will always keep it
Anonymous and you can write in about
anything we appreciate you guys being
vulnerable and sharing the safe space
with us and being open to
self-reflection yes because sometimes
like when people write in it's hard for
us to say it but like you the person
writing in like you are the problem no
but everyone can when there's a problem
everyone has contributed to it so to
recognize for the most part that we've
seen some like girl number one you
didn't do anything wrong yeah
um so to recognize the role that you
play in something is very powerful
it is and I've enjoyed that immensely so
thank you for that we're bordering on
another 90 minute episode I gotta have
to pee so [ __ ] so bad I'm gonna have
to stop drinking coffee during these
episodes because you know what I was
thinking the same thing I am going to
have to stop drinking water or coffee
because it's not normal it's too much
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast and Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts and what podcast can be
found so that's Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio iheartradiocastbox all the
places where we listen to podcasts find
out some morning toast leave a five star
via better beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an amazing
hump day and we'll see you tomorrow for
my funny girl review and we'll see you
then yeah bye